alors bonjour madame la ministre merci
d'être parmi nous aujourd'hui alors
c'est vrai que compte tenu des
circonstances
de transport
il y a pas mal de collègues et ont dû
qui ont dû quitter le Sénat hier soir
alors vous avez peut-être pas la
quantité mais je vous rassure vous avez
la qualité
donc
donc je vais commencer tout de suite
parce que ben voilà qui va
tu peux enlever ton masque
donc
le président Rapin reçoit aujourd'hui
dans son département la visite du
président du Sénat
aussi il m'a prier de le suppléer pour
présider cette réunion ce matin
en tous les cas nous avons le plaisir de
les collègues qui arrivent
ils font plaisir de la qualité en plus
densifie
nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
aujourd'hui madame Laurence Beaune donc
secrétaire d'État auprès de la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
chargées de l'Europe afin qu'elle nous
rende compte du Conseil européen des 23
et 24 mars dernier alors une fois de
plus l'Ukraine a constitué évidemment un
point majeur de son ordre du jour sur ce
sujet nous sommes particulièrement
mobilisés madame ministre concernant les
transferts forcés d'enfants
ukrainien notre commission à adopter à
cet effet une proposition de résolution
européenne examiner hier même par la
commission des affaires étrangères de
notre assemblée
et donc appeler à devenir dans quelques
jours une résolution définitive du Sénat
donc à ce propos à propos de ce problème
des enfants déportés
avez-vous des éléments plus précis à
nous apporter à la suite de ce conseil
au sujet notamment de l'initiative
conjointe de la Pologne et de la
Commission européenne annoncé le 27
février dernier et destiné à recueillir
des données et des preuves
nous nous interrogeons notamment sur son
articulation avec l'enquête menée par
Euro juste
notre proposition de résolution appelle
l'Union européenne à élargir ses
sanctions à l'ensemble des parties
prenantes au système entre guillemets
mise en place pour déporter et russifier
les enfants Ukrainiens dans ces
conclusions le Conseil européen envisage
de nouvelles sanctions est-ce qu'elle
pourrait aller dans le sens que nous
préconisons
il confirme aussi la nécessité d'éviter
le contournement des sanctions à ce
sujet le bureau de la commission a pu
échanger la semaine dernière avec
Monsieur Denis Redonnet qui est très
intéressant d'ailleurs directeur général
joint de la DG trade de la Commission
européenne est chargée d'assurer le
respect des règles du commerce ce
dernier a estimé que les sanctions
frappaient
50% des exportations et 70% des
importations de la Russie et que leur
impact était réel et qu'il irait
croissant à condition toutefois dans
l'éviter justement les contournements
notamment via la Turquie et l'Asie
centrale comment l'Union peut-elle
efficacement diminuer minimiser ce
contournement nous notons aussi la pluie
que le Conseil européen affiche en vers
la Moldavie
confronté à des manœuvres internes de
déstabilisation c'est que c'est un pays
un peu particulier avec la Transnistrie
et avec une partie russophone une
délégation de notre commission si rendra
à la fin du mois pour manifester au
niveau parlementaire le soutien de notre
pays et soutient dont vous avez déjà
témoigné madame la ministre en vous
rendant à chissino
début mars
second canton jeu de ce Conseil européen
la compétitivité la résilience et
l'autonomie européenne
je dirais la souveraineté à ce sujet
j'aimerais vous alerter sur quelques
points de vigilance le premier concerne
la réforme du marché de l'électricité
dont on parle beaucoup bien sûr le
Conseil européen encourage ton adoption
d'ici la fin de l'année alors qu'elle a
été présentée le mois dernier par la
Commission européenne c'est-à-dire très
court au vu des premiers réactions des
États membres jugez vous que c'est
réalistes cette proposition
le second concerne l'intelligence
artificielle le Conseil européen
encourage le recours aux outils
numériques et en temps soutenir des
entreprises du secteur pour que l'Union
européenne reste à l'avant-garde dans ce
domaine or l'Italie vient de décider
d'interdire l'usage du robot
conversationnel
d'openhaye et chat GPT
qui ne respecterait pas la
réglementation européenne en matière de
protection des données
notre commission vient d'ailleurs
d'adopter une proposition de résolution
européenne appelant à un déploiement de
l'intelligence artificielle conforme aux
valeurs européennes
la décision italienne vient miner
évidemment l'Union l'unité européenne
sur ce dossier structurant pour l'avenir
savez-vous comment l'Union compte réagir
enfin dernier sujet sur lequel je
souhaite attirer votre attention le
Conseil européen confirme sa volonté de
réduire les dépendances européennes sur
ces chaînes de production stratégique et
notamment sur la microélectronique c'est
notamment l'objet du chips Act porté par
la commission par le commissaire breton
alors breton c'est son nom c'est pas un
Breton comme moi
lui c'est de Chérie voilà
et destiné à réduire notre dépendance en
semi-conducteur
or il nous remonte du terrain aux uns et
aux autres des inquiétudes fortes les
industrielles estiment que ce plan
breton vise la production en Europe de
puces dans les caractéristiques ne
répondent pas aux besoins de l'industrie
ainsi stellanis serait freiné dans sa
production par le manque de ses puces
que la Chine produit mais dont elle a
réduit l'exportation pour fournir sa
propre industrie
dans les besoins augmente le
gouvernement a-t-il été sensibilisé à ce
sujet
donc Madame la Ministre j'ai
suffisamment parlé et les grands temps
de vous laisser la parole
donc je vous la laisse et les collègues
vous poseront les questions qu'ils ont
envie de vous poser après
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président et
merci pour votre accueil je sais que
c'est effectivement une journée de grève
j'ai apprécie d'autant plus la qualité
de la réunion que vous avez rassemblé
ici un grand merci
d'être là pour discuter effectivement
des avancées du dernier Conseil européen
donc merci à tous et mesdames laissées
natrices et Messieurs messieurs
on va dire que si vous êtes sûr
voilà donc c'est un plaisir de vous
retrouver ici merci pour vos questions
je vais faire le propos luminaire et
puis vous voulez j'enchaîne sur la
réponse au point que vous avez soulevé
aussi voilà donc il y avait trois
questions principales à l'ordre du jour
du dernier Conseil européen le premier
et la première était bien évidemment le
soutien à l'Ukraine la deuxième priorité
qui a été traitée par le Conseil était
la compétitivité donc ce qui comprend la
réponse européenne à une fashion
réduction acte mais aussi vous l'avez
mentionné la situation énergétique et
puis le dernier point il y a eu un point
migration et un peu commerce dont nous
pourrons reparler comme vous savez
Antonio guteres le secrétaire général
des Nations Unies a d'abord fait une
intervention conseil c'était l'occasion
de de rappeler qu'il est important de
renforcer la coopération entre l'un ion
européenne et l'ONU surtout à l'aune de
la guerre en Ukraine c'était aussi un
moyen de souligner la nécessité d'une
réponse multilatérale face à la
violation flagrante des principes
fondamentaux de la Charte des Nations
et puis bien évidemment de traiter de
tous les sujets que l'on appelle des
biens publics mondiaux la protection de
l'environnement la lutte contre la
pollution la préservation des
écosystèmes la santé mondiale la
sécurité alimentaire et le financement
de l'aide humanitaire
sur l'Ukraine donc le Conseil européen a
rappelé bien évidemment sur le soutien
indéfectible à l'Ukraine ça son unité je
crois que c'est très important dans
cette période la détermination d'Union
européenne a maintenir et puis aussi à
accroître la pression collective sur la
Russie y compris en poursuivant les
travaux sur les mesures sur les
restrictions les sanctions et leur
application uniformes et à continuer de
travailler avec ses partenaires sur le
plafonnement du prix du pétrole
effectivement il a été à l'ordre du jour
la nécessité d'assurer la mise en oeuvre
effective des sanctions de lutter contre
le contournement dans les pays tiers et
par les pays tiers et je reviendrai
là-dessus tout à l'heure et puis enfin
le Conseil a donné à de nouveaux
apporter son soutien à l'Assemblée à la
résolution de l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies pour une paix juste et
durable qui a été votée le 23 février
dernier ainsi qu'aux plan de paix
proposé par le président zellinski
voilà la nouveauté du Conseil c'était
bien évidemment le soutien à l'accord
trouvé en vue de livrer d'urgence des
munitions à l'Ukraine c'est ce qui avait
demandé le président ukrainien au début
du mois de février et pour cela il y a
trois points d'action la première chose
c'est l'utilisation des stocks existants
des États membres pour la livraison des
missiles et des munitions
le second c'est le renforcement des
capacités de production de l'Union
européenne et nous avons vraiment besoin
de monter en puissance et le troisième
c'est un dispositif d'achat conjoint
avec bien sûr en filigrane que ce soit
les financements européens servent à
acheter les productions européennes
il y a aussi eu des discussions et un
soutien à la poursuite des travaux sur
la lutte contre l'impunité et vous
l'avez mentionné notamment les
enlèvements et les déportations forcés
d'enfants vers la Russie c'est
évidemment inacceptable et ses actions
ne peuvent pas rester impuni et donc
j'ai salue monsieur le Président la
proposition de résolution européenne
proposé par le sénateur André gatolin et
adopté sur ce même sujet le 29 mars et
je crois que c'est vraiment fondamental
que sur un sujet aussi grave que
celui-ci il y a une expression forte et
ferme du Parlement et de façon
rassemblée et d'ailleurs en accueillant
au Sénat le premier février dernier le
président de la Rada ukrainienne vous
avez témoigné de ce soutien d'effectible
de la France et de son parlement à
l'Ukraine
alors le deuxième point qui était à
l'ordre du jour du conseil donc les
enjeux économiques et la compétitivité
je crois que sur la lancée du sommet de
Versailles en mars l'année dernière et
vraiment la dynamique vers une stratégie
de souveraineté européenne conforme à
nos ambitions écologiques qui est en
train de se déployer de se mettre en
oeuvre et c'est ce que l'on a vu avec
les orientations du Conseil européen et
la présentation des travaux de la
commission pour avancer en pratique donc
c'est vraiment une accélération de la
manière dont l'Europe appréhende des
défis économiques et industriels à
laquelle nous sommes en train d'assister
si vous me le permettez je vais passer
en revue les différents textes qui
sous-tendent ou qui sont les piliers de
cette stratégie
et qui en fait contribue à former
vraiment ce qu'on appelle la main d'une
Europe stratégique qui avait été exposé
dans la note des autorités françaises du
9 janvier donc il y a ce pilier vraiment
qui est le premier une vision
industrielle ambitieuse qui est de fixer
des objectifs à l'horizon 2030 pour
inciter à l'implantation des capacités
de production européenne qui répondent à
nos besoins stratégiques les matières
premières les semi-conducteurs vous
l'avez évoqué ou encore les et bien sûr
les technologies qui participent à la
transition verte
l'objectif premier d'abord c'est de
réduire les dépendances de l'Union
européenne aux énergies fossiles et de
d'arriver à réaliser la transition
écologique en créant des emplois et donc
les propositions de la Commission qui
ont été prises dans cette direction que
ce soit les mesures prises en matière
d'être d'État que ce soit les mesures
qui permettent à l'Union européenne de
se protéger contre les distorsions de
concurrence créée par des dispositions
étrangères les règlements sectoriels sur
l'industrie net 0 aussi émissions et les
matières premières critiques tout cela
forme un socle de travail évidemment il
faudra que les financements soient à la
hauteur des ambitions affichées et que
l'assouplissement réglementaire soit à
la fois efficace et lisible pour nos
entreprises
et puis juste un petit point et nous
pour je fure nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir le principe essentiel de
neutralité technologique qui doit
laisser et qui laisse la liberté des
États membres de définir souverainement
leur propre bouquets énergétique doit
être préservée
enfin pour
sur ce propos un peu général sur le
renforcement de la politique
industrielle il y a évidemment un besoin
de renforcer nos capacités
d'investissement public et privés
notamment dans la recherche
développement et la formation puisque
tous les pays dans l'Union européenne
sont au plein emploi dans beaucoup de
secteurs et donc il faudra à la fois
l'achèvement l'Union des marchés de
capitaux et de l'Union bancaire mais
aussi répondre à la question des
compétences ce qui est présenté dans les
différents règlements de la commission
il faut absolument que nous arrivions à
augmenter notre vivier de talent
européen et pour cela nous avons besoin
de diversifier les offres de formation
de les associer mieux aux entreprises de
même que les offres de reconversion à la
fois pour répondre aux besoins existants
mais aussi aux besoins futurs dans les
secteurs clés
voilà la question du fond de
souveraineté elle a été reportée au
prochain Conseil européen qui se tiendra
en juin
un petit point là dessus sur ce dernier
sur ce dernier volant industriel qui est
vraiment très clair on a de quoi assurer
nos matières premières avec de la
diversification et des une stratégie
commune pour aller chercher les matières
premières là où elles sont et de façon
diversifiées et puis aussi en extraire
chez nous de façon propre et si nous en
avons le deuxième point qui est
effectivement d'investir dans les
secteurs stratégiques avec des moyens
financiers le troisième point qui est
une simplification réglementaire des
aides d'État et on inclut les crédits
d'impôts parce que ça va très vite et
c'est facile à mettre en oeuvre
et le quatrième point qui attrait à la
protection du marché intérieur et à son
à son essor et là je pense aux
instruments en tissuventions vous avez
rencontré le directeur adjoint de
du département des échanges il vous en a
parlé j'en suis sûr des instruments
antidumpig des instruments
anticoercession de la nécessité d'avoir
de la répulsiprocité nous avons un
instrument maintenant pour l'accès au
marché intérieur et bien sûr le volant
commerce international qui a deux
éléments
essentiels c'est que nous concluons des
accords internationaux si et à condition
que les engagements pris au titre des
accords de Paris
ainsi qu'en matière de climat et de
biodiversité soit respecté et la
deuxième condition c'est la réciprocité
des standards et des normes européennes
de façon à ce que quand un produit
arrive sur nos marchés il satisfait au
même règlement que ce que nous demandons
à nos producteurs y compris nos
agriculteurs
voilà un dernier petit point sur ce plan
économique et je passe à l'énergie qui
est la révision de la gouvernance
économique donc comme vous savez des
conclusions avaient été adoptées en
conseil et copines du 14 mars dernier
sur la politique économique de la zone
euro la Commission va présenter dans les
prochaines semaines une proposition
législative et bien sûr nous serons très
attentifs puisque c'est là que nous
verrons les détails de ce qui est
proposé
l'objectif étant d'assurer la
soutenabilité de nos finances publiques
la croissance et les investissements
sur la situation énergétique alors
plusieurs choses importantes aussi la
première
c'est l'hiver prochain donc des mesures
de stockage de continuer à réduire le
gaz nous l'avons déjà nous avons déjà
réduit notre consommation de gaz de 20%
l'hiver dernier en européen ce qui est
colossal et puis une plateforme d'achat
conjoint qui va nous permettre de
coordonner les achats de gaz donc de pas
tout se précipiter au même moment
poussant l'esprit les prix à la hausse
mais au contraire d'utiliser notre
pouvoir de marché pour pousser les prix
à la baisse et les stocks en sortie de
l'hiver dans l'Union européenne comme
vous savez sont plutôt mieux qu'attendu
sur
sur l'énergie toujours donc il y a
évidemment la question
de la réforme du marché de l'électricité
et avant ça je crois que c'est le moment
pour moi de saluer également monsieur le
Président vous initiative dont
l'organisation au sein de cette même
commission d'une table ronde sur le
thème de l'Europe face à la nouvelle
politique de l'énergie le 2 mars dernier
à nouveau plus plus nous sommes portés
par les propositions et les travaux du
Parlement plus il est facile de pas
facile en tous les cas ça nous aide
beaucoup à asseoir nos objectifs mais
c'est sincère
sur la réforme donc du marché de
l'exélectricité vous l'avez mentionné
effectivement nous souhaitons l'adoption
de la réforme d'ici la fin 2023 tout en
respectant les prérogatives du Parlement
européen donc ce ne sera pas les
procédures d'urgence que nous avons
cette vue cet hiver mais une procédure
accélérée probablement et là l'objectif
il est clair il est de permettre de
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat de nos
ménages et la compétitivité de nos
entreprises surtout dans le contexte
économique et social qui est celui que
vous connaissez
est-ce que nous avons vu des premières
propositions va également dans ce sens
puisqu'elle permet de prendre en compte
les capacités nucléaires existantes et
d'offrir la possibilité de faire des
contrats de long terme sur la base de
ses capacités de production qui vont
nous permettre de nous éloigner du prix
du gaz que nous avons vu donc de ce
qu'on appelle le découplage et de faire
baisser
les prix
il est évidemment important de je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure de respecter la
neutralité technologique c'est dans ce
papier de réforme proposé par la
Commission qui doit bien sûr être
débattue maintenant avec tous les États
membres mais c'est extrêmement important
pour nous et nous continuerons
évidemment de nos battre pour que reste
ce principe de neutralité technologique
et notamment la reconnaissance du rôle
que peut jouer l'énergie nucléaire dans
la décarbonation de nos économies donc
voilà dans le volet économique on avait
à la fois tout ce qui est politique
industriel tout ce qui est net 0 une
émission qui en fait notre réponse à
l'IRA et qui est la même taille que les
rats et puis la réforme du marché
d'électricité les prix de l'énergie
étant le socle de notre compétitivité
enfin il y a eu un suivi des conclusions
du Conseil européen de février en
matière de migration là c'était vraiment
l'occasion pour la commission de faire
un point d'étape sur les actions qui ont
été conduites depuis le Conseil européen
de début février
il peut être deux points là dessus
d'abord en matière extérieure
l'importance du travail avec les pays
tiers et les pays d'origine a été
rappelé et puis en matière de dimension
intérieure le Conseil européen a appelé
les collégislateurs à poursuivre les
négociations en cours sur le pacte sur
la migration et l'Asie qui avance au
Parlement européen en vue d'une adoption
à la fin de la législature voilà donc
monsieur le Président et Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
les enjeux du Conseil européen
souhaitez-vous que je réponde plus
précisément aux questions que vous
m'avez posé tout de suite ou que je
prenne quelques quelques questions si
vous le souhaitez et puis après on
passera la parole alors
sur les enfants
ukrainiens
je crois que d'abord il faut il faut le
dire le caractère massif des
déportations d'enfants et du processus
d'assimilation forcée mise en oeuvre par
les autorités russes et avéré et nous
avons des témoignages qui ont été requis
qui ont recueilli pardon auprès de la
Commission des Droits de l'Homme de la
radar le Parlement ukrainien ou recensé
par la plateforme qui a été mise en
ligne par le gouvernement ukrainien de
child of War et ils font tous états de
milliers d'enfants qui ont été
transférés de force
et comme l'a dit l'ONU et cela est
constitutif de crimes de guerre les
responsables de ces crimes les
responsables russes de ces crimes seront
donc jugés
l'initiative conjointe que vous avez
mentionné lancer le 27 février par la
Commission européenne et la Pologne et
très très importante à nos yeux et nous
laisse soutenons elle vise comme vous
savez à recueillir les données et les
preuves afin de traduire en justice les
responsables et les complices de ces
crimes et elle doit aussi nous permettre
quelque chose d'essentiel qui est
d'obtenir des informations précises sur
le sort de ces enfants et leur lieu
d'établissement la France est par
ailleurs depuis plusieurs mois favorable
à l'adoption de sanctions européennes
contre des personnes ou institutions
russes qui contribuent au déportation
d'enfants
Ukrainiens donc il s'agit de geler les
avoir des personnes responsables de ces
crimes de leur interdire de voyager et
des dizaines de désignations ont été
déjà adoptées dans le cadre des dix
paquets de sanctions contre la Russie
nous allons travailler à les renforcer
dans le cadre des prochaines
négociations à Bruxelles
sur
le contournement des sanctions que je
vous avais mis de côté car c'est
effectivement
le point d'attention pour nous dans les
dans les mois qui viennent alors juste
pour rappel en les sanctions visent 1473
personnes à ce stade 25 entités qui sont
responsables d'avoir soutenu financé ou
participer à cette agression et tous
ceux qui en tirent avantage vous avez
émotionné les les sanctions économiques
il y en a aussi contre la Biélorussie et
contre l'Iran en l'utilisant en raison
de l'utilisation des drones iraniens
dans l'agression russe contre l'Ukraine
et contre des personnes liées au groupe
Wagner qui opèrent notamment en Afrique
et qui contribue au financement de
l'effort de guerre russe
en ce qui concerne les le contournement
c'est vrai que nous voulons absolument
empêcher la réexportation vers la Russie
par l'intermédiaire de pays tiers de
biens et de matériaux européens qui sont
sensibles et sous sanctions susceptibles
d'être utilisé notamment à des fins
militaires ou dans des secteurs
stratégiques puisque cela s'apprête les
efforts que nous faisons donc ce que la
France fait en ce moment aussi de
travailler avec d'autres États membres à
des pistes de coopération concrètes qui
permettent d'empêcher la réexportation
vers la Russie par l'intermédiaire de
pays tiers de bien et de matériaux
européens qui sont sensibles et sous
sanctions et nous avons maintenant un
envoyé spécial de l'Union européenne
pour les sanctions David O'Sullivan qui
lui est en train d'effectuer les
démarches diplomatiques auprès des pays
tiers et notamment avec nos partenaires
britanniques et américains nous avons si
c'est le contournement et ils sont et
documenté il reste maintenant à
en fait à vraiment mettre en oeuvre avec
les pays et leur faire comprendre que le
contournement c'est passible aussi de
répression
pardon
non ce sera pas le plus simple mais il
faut le faire quand même vous avez
raison en ce qui concerne la
Moldavie et vous avez mentionné les
tentatives de déstabilisation
effectivement que dans la présidence
parle beaucoup et qui inquiète le
gouvernement moldave je crois que nous
pouvons les aider de trois façons
d'abord avec leur besoin administratifs
pour acquis mettre en place les acquis
de l'Union européenne il faut une
structure administrative importante
qualifiée la présidente moldave fait
venir des expatriés moldavres pour
l'aider à mettre ça en œuvre mais ce
n'est pas suffisant et nous demandons à
la Commission européenne de fournir plus
de personnes pour aider
les moldavres à mettre en
d'abord écrire puis mettre en mettre en
oeuvre tout ce qui est nécessaire pour
passer du statut de candidat à celui
d'ouverture des négociations le Conseil
de l'Europe vous aider aussi donc il
faut faire de la pression je compte sur
vous également sur ces institutions la
deuxième chose c'est la communauté
politique européenne qui évidemment un
poids pour la Moldavie pas facile
d'organiser une telle conférence quand
on est ce pays mais qui néanmoins va
permettre de mettre les projecteurs
internationaux sur la Moldavie qui va
conforter sa place dans la famille
européenne et qui permet aussi au pays
de proposer des aides bilatérale pour
continuer à soutenir ses efforts et puis
la troisième chose c'est la
désinformation comme vous savez la
Moldavie a fermé les chaînes de
télévision russe elle n'a donc plus de
contenu
beaucoup moins de contenu et au retour
de mon voyage en Moldavie j'ai contacté
Arte qui est très gentiment mais va
mettre du contenu gratuit à disposition
de la Moldavie pour que y ait un flux de
documentaire d'informations de films qui
soient européen et pas forcément russe
ou biélorus et qui permettent aux
personnes d'être
sensible à notre culture aussi et ça je
crois que c'est très important parce que
sinon ils vont tourner tomber et
effectivement sur de l'information russe
ou autre
vous avez
le plan de
oui le plan breton absolument sur le
chips
alors d'abord je crois que
c'est ce que j'ai dit aux États-Unis la
semaine dernière et à l'administration
américaine vous avez un chips actes nous
avons un chips actes vous avez une
flèche de réduction nous avons un être
zéro et industriel vous êtes très
important mais nous avons encore plus de
consommateurs que vous et nous faisons
plus d'échanges commerciaux nous sommes
la région économique la plus importante
du monde alors le
chips actes français qui effectivement
s'occupe d'approvisionnement au
semi-conducteur en particulier pour
l'industrie technologique mais aussi
automobile pardon mais aussi le
développement technologique
pour la maîtrise de la production des
puces de deux nm
ce qu'on leur dénégociations au conseil
au départ on n'était parti sur la notion
d'installation pionnière donc des puces
qui sont des États pour des puces et des
projets technologiques soit extrêmement
novateurs ce que nous avons fait nous en
France c'est de demander que ce soit un
peu plus large et que ce chips actes
puissent soutenir des projets
industriels qui soient basés sur des
topologies plus matures et pas seulement
sur les puces de 2 NM ce que je crois
correspond à la question que vous avez
aussi et c'est vrai que quand on regarde
ce qui se fait aux États-Unis il couvre
un ensemble de technologie qui soit un
peu plus larges
à nouveau je pense qu'il faut qu'on au
fur et à mesure où on avance si vous
entendez sur le terrain qu'il y a des
choses à corriger compléter ou à
demander c'est très important de les
faire remonter pour qu'on puisse porter
cela à la Commission et au Parlement
européen quand on
quand on a discuté
fort vers l'Union européenne j'imagine
je n'en doute pas le président de toute
façon elle fait effectivement ce qu'il
faut dans tous les sujets sur tous les
sujets et je crois que sur les semis
conducteurs et les particulièrement
attentif à deux choses la première c'est
comme vous savez la production de
semi-conducteurs est concentrée à 80% à
Taïwan donc le besoin de diversification
quoi qu'on qu'il arrive et quoi qu'on
dise il est très important et ça je
crois que depuis la crise covid les
Etats-Unis comme l'Europe s'en est rendu
compte la deuxième chose c'est nous
avons une voix à nous européen qui est
distincte de celle des Américains vous
connaissez l'affaire ASML des Pays-Bas
où les États-Unis ont essayé de bloquer
l'exportation de toute une gamme de
semi-conducteurs et où en fait la
Hollande les Pays-Bas ont décidé
eux-mêmes de ce qui constituait une
technologie qui ne voulait pas exporter
et ce qui est encore plus intéressant
ils ont inscrit le règlement pour faire
ça dans un règlement européen et je
crois que c'est une des facettes que
nous avons à compléter et à consolider
au niveau européen c'est d'avoir une
doctrine sur les exportations que nous
voulons faire au delà des exportations
de bien à double usage qui est la
doctrine qui existe aujourd'hui
vous m'avez parlé de l'intelligence
artificielle et de chaque GPT vous
voulez que j'en dise de moi aussi
après vous avez trouvé que je suis trop
longue
mais alors
tchat j'ai pété comme d'autres
applications sont sous et soumis aux
obligations génériques qui sont prévues
dans le règlement qui qui traite de
l'intelligence artificielle et en
particulier en matière de transparence
et puis je crois qu'il faut dire que les
développeurs sont très attentifs au
biais qui ont été détectés et le mettre
à jour régulièrement leur application
pour en maîtriser les risques de dérive
ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui c'est que
les applications comme chat GPT ne
rentre pas en première analyse dans le
champ des catégories des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle à haut
risque en revanche en revanche des
usages de chaque GPT pour relever eux
des systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
à haut risque et donc pour que nous
adaption les règles il faut que nous
fassions la différence entre le modèle
d'intelligence artificielle en lui-même
et les usages qui vont en être faits et
donc je peux vous assurer que les
société française sont très attentives à
l'influence et aux évolutions des
discussions sur ce point
et je crois pas que interdire
brutalement sans évaluer ces différences
ou à efficaces puisque le monde internet
dépasse nos frontières merci
merci beaucoup
je vais maintenant passer la parole à
nos collègues alors on était pas très
nombreux au départ on l'est un peu plus
et chacun d'entre eux vous poser une
question ce qui prouve l'intérêt il
porte à ce que vous dites André et
Rachad
merci Président le ministre merci pour
pour ces informations
moi j'aurais voulu vous interroger plus
particulièrement sur la deuxième partie
de votre exposé consacrée à la
compétitivité
de l'Union européenne
vous avez mentionné que l'on avait
progressé en matière de défense
commerciale
moi j'ai lu j'ai pris la peine de
recopier les conclusions du communiqué à
l'issue du conseil j'ai lu qu'un
c'est des mots les mots exacts qu'un
débat stratégique avait eu lieu sur les
aspects géopolitiques du commerce et que
celui-ci a mis en avant la contribution
de la politique commerciale à la
compétitivité de l'Union européenne
point
je trouve que c'est un peu short quand
même pour un
communiqué conclusif d'un conseil des
ministres de l'Union européenne est-ce
que vous pourriez nous développer un peu
plus que ce que vous n'avez fait les
tendances
les orientations à venir de cette
politique commerciale on a naturellement
tous entendu le ministre de l'Économie
des Finances Bruno Le Maire nous dire
que au sein de l'Union européenne il
fallait absolument s'engager en faveur
d'une préférence européenne préférence
commerciale européenne moi j'ai je dis
bravo
joie rien venir comme ça dans l'état que
les choses est-ce que quelque chose à
venir plus généralement sur cela
Charles Michel lui-même avait plaidé il
y a peu de temps pour améliorer la
méthode de négociation des accords
commerciaux et
favoriser tout particulièrement vu les
difficultés à avancer dans ce domaine
favoriser
leur approbation par les États membres
vous savez que chez nous nous sommes
particulièrement attentifs notamment ce
qui va se passer sur le Mercosur comme
on l'a d'ailleurs été par le passé donc
je m'inquiète un peu de la réponse de la
Commission qui est de scinder les
accords pour ne laisser à l'examen des
parlements nationaux que la portion
congrue laquelle correspond aux
compétences partagées entre l'Union et
les États membres
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure madame la
ministre le président de la République
Insee a déclaré que la France
s'opposerait à tout traité qui ne
respecterait pas les accords de Paris ou
qui ne contiendrait contiendrait pas ce
qu'on appelle les clauses miroir
est-ce que sur ce plan là cette position
de la Commission
ne nous ferait pas perdre de scinder
donc vous l'avez compris comme je viens
de l'expliquer
ne serait pas perdre une capacité de
veto s'il accorde association qui exige
normalement un accord unanime des États
membres devait se transformer en un
simple accord de libre-échange
calibré sur les compétences exclusives
de l'Union européenne dès lors seule une
majorité qualifiée serait exigée donc
moi je m'inquiète un peu de ça
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rassurer sur
cette volonté de l'Union européenne
véritablement de faire en sorte que
enfin on dépasse les mots voilà que on
pour faire clair on s'engage
véritablement être à la hauteur de ce
formidable défi qui nous est imposé par
notamment Lyra dont vous disiez que
maintenant naturellement sur le plan
industriel on en prend vraiment la
mesure mais sur le plan commercial je
répète et c'est le but de ma question
l'objectif de ma question moi j'ai le
sentiment que ça avance toujours pas et
ce que j'ai lu tout à l'heure sur ce
communiqué conclusif du Conseil
m'inquiète vraiment prochain conseil
vous l'avez dit c'est au mois de juin
encore deux mois de deux mois d'attente
j'espère que ce ne sont pas de moi de
perdu enfin bref vous l'avez compris
c'est bien d'être à la hauteur sur le
blanc sur le plan industriel si tenté
qu'on le devienne un jour pour l'Union
européenne je parle mais après il faut
gérer la question commerciale et et à
mon sens là
on n'y est pas encore merci on va
prendre trois questions si vous êtes
d'accord et puis
une information j'ai oublié de vous
préciser début de cette réunion cette
réunion elle est captée et retransmise
en direct donc voilà ça vous évitera de
dire des bêtises
donc et justement j'allais passer la
parole à André gadola
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre merci d'avoir salué notre
initiative concernant les enfants
Ukrainiens il faut rendre à César ce qui
appartient à César j'ai travaillé avec
l'association l'ONG de chercheurs
français pour l'Ukraine leur liberté et
la nôtre et je rappelle que si la CPI
s'est engagé c'est parce que en décembre
dernier on a déposé avec des juristes
internationaux très gros dossier donc je
pense qu'il faut quand même rappeler que
la France a le leadership et
l'initiative là-dessus je dois dire que
les retours que j'ai eu aussi bien de
l'Ukraine mais aussi d'un certain nombre
de pays nous reconnaissa et hier
effectivement dans l'étude tu as dit que
ça avait été étudié à la Commission des
affaires des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées elle était
adoptée à l'unanimité comme lors de
notre commission et je tiens à remercier
effectivement toutes cette commission
parce que je crois que c'est important
je rappelle qu'il y a une liste de 109
personnes impliquées établies par les
Ukrainiens dont une partie plusieurs
dizaines ont été validées par les
autorités polonaises qui font un travail
de vérification et je pense que ça
serait bien de se baser sur cette liste
sur les sanctions à venir dans le 11e
paquet dans les éléments importants il y
a la question de l'application effective
des sanctions il y a pas que la Turquie
il y a énormément aujourd'hui on le sait
et puis il y a une petite des petites
flottes commerciales
d'État non-européen mais aussi d'État
européen qui rompent assez
systématiquement difficilement
repérables la question que je me pose
c'est que c'est aussi dans les fonctions
de Frontex Frontex n'est pas là
uniquement pour réguler les flux de
migration
où elle est là aussi pour s'assurer
des de la du fonctionnement douanier et
je pense qu'en la matière
il faudrait aussi se mobiliser en termes
d'effectivité et face au contournement
des sanctions faudrait trouver un
mécanisme pour faire cela vous avez
évoqué la question de la Moldavie et de
la désinformation vous avez parlé d'Arté
moi je regrette que on a une chaîne
excellente qui s'appelle rognews qu'on
est en train de laisser mourir qui
abandonnaient c'est la seule chaîne qui
parle de l'Europe si on fait par
angonnage pour parler français avec les
autres chaînes en tous les cas de langue
française c'est la seule qui parle
véritablement d'Europe tous les jours et
je pense que là je tiens un signal
d'alarme en fait enfin dernière question
il y a des bruits et des rumeurs qui
courent sur une volonté de la part de la
Commission de réouvrir le caille
l'accord d'investissement Union
européenne Chine et comme actuellement
nous avons madame vanderlain qui est à
côté du président Macron en visite en
Chine
chose étonnante quand même le BDI c'est
à dire la fédération de l'industrie
allemande a publié un communiqué
avant-hier mettant en cause cette
réouverture en disant nous y étions
favorables au début des négociations les
choses sont tellement changées nous
alertons notre gouvernement et le
gouvernement des extrêmement prudent
alors je pense qu'il ne se passera rien
avant les élections européennes parce
que le Parlement européen était bloqué
mais on sent bien que entre Monsieur
Michel et Madame vanderlione il y a il y
a une différence d'appréciation et je
crois que il serait pas de bonne alloi
de repartir tout de suite sur des
négociations à ce niveau là qui ont
provoqué tant de mots scènes de pignon
voilà je vous remercie
merci André Jacques ferrique merci
Président Madame ministre en préambule
un point d'urgence parce qu'on est le 6
avril et c'est la date limite pour que
les États se joignent s'il le souhaite à
la Commission et au Parlement pour
déposer leurs observations sur le
recours à la cour de justice contre la
Hongrie qui n'a pas abrogé sa loi contre
l'homosexualité il y a 11 États qui
l'ont fait la France à ma connaissance
manque à l'appel c'est assez
incompréhensible
concernant donc la la guerre menée par
la Russie donc la résolution du conseil
à maintenir à accroître la pression
collective sur la Russie compris au
moyen de restrictif supplémentaire c'est
tout à fait positif je regrette je
l'avais déjà dit que notre gouvernement
est fait en sorte qu'on soit écarté le
secteur nucléaire il n'y a pas d'embargo
sur l'uranium russe il y a pas de
sanction des cadres importants du
nucléaire russe
en bref le nucléaire russe est à l'abri
des sanctions d'une certaine façon notre
nationalisme industriel le protège
madame la ministre est-ce que c'est
entêtement aura une limite vous avez
parlé vous parlez souvent de neutralité
technologique mais dans ce conflit je
crois que les intérêts nucléaires russes
liés aux nôtres ne sont pas neutres sur
la politique industrielle européenne
notre président promettait une stratégie
industrielle forte inédite offensive
face à Lyra américain
le plan de la commission n'est pas tout
à fait à la hauteur
ce qu'il n'y a-t-il aucun changement de
cap possible venant du Conseil parce que
on n'a pas d'investissement
fort nouveau financé par une dette
commune le fond de souveraineté
industrielle il paraît repoussé aux
calandre le fond social
il est toujours un peu faiblard
on a la
flexibilité sans condition des aides
d'État ou le flou des critères de
sécurité d'approvisionnement je crains
qu'on soit pas encore là-dessus dans la
clarté dans la cohérence et puis surtout
l'absence d'un bail européen Act qui
serait nécessaire comment on peut ne pas
chercher à renforcer nos industries en
privilégiant dans nos marchés publics la
production en Europe
enfin en insistant sur ce que disait mon
voisin sur les accords commerciaux
où sont concrètement les mesures miroir
promises leur robustesse et puis et les
dispositifs pour en assurer
l'application réelle au-delà des
annonces
beaucoup de choses mais
tu prends la parole et puis après on
vous laissera répondre madame merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je voudrais revenir sur la stratégie de
souveraineté européenne que vous avez
évoquée
ainsi que son accélération et en savoir
un petit peu plus alors les nouvelles
propositions
ont été annoncés dans le domaine
commercial et
c'est un centre de mesure ambitionne de
répondre bien sûr à l'inflation à l'IRA
américain
et il est important que l'Europe puisse
jouer à armes égales avec les autres
grandes puissances c'est évident c'est
l'objet du pacte
vers industriel
j'aimerais que vous en disiez un petit
peu plus sur ce sujet
aujourd'hui le président de la
République cela a été évoqué est en
visite d'État en Chine avec Madame
vanderleyen il y aura peut-être d'autres
mesures aussi concernant les relations
commerciales avec la Chine
quelle est la stratégie pour un made in
Europe dont on a parlé
ce made in Europe pourrait être plus
compétitif pour le marché européen
est-ce que on lançait un petit peu plus
et une autre question
concernant les offres de formation de
reconversion que vous avez évoqué
est-ce que il y a
des annonces pour aller plus loin
dans le marché de l'Europe merci
merci beaucoup Colette madame
la ministre vous pouvez peut-être
répondre à nos trois autres collègues
pendant la parole
merci beaucoup merci alors
vos questions se recoupent donc ce qui
va me permettre de vous faire une
réponse extensive et mais je l'espère
synthétique aussi je crois qu'il faut
être
il faut être très juste et très réaliste
les moins bons moteurs de l'Europe ce
sont les Européens eux-mêmes je peux
vous assurer que quand on explique aux
Américains ce qu'on est en train de
faire il vous regarde d'un autre œil
alors je vais je vais vous le faire
comme je l'ai fait là bas
4 piliers le premier pilier c'est le
plan industriel dont le nez de zéro
industrie acte qui est la réponse à lire
c'est une réponse financière de même
ampleur que l'inflation réduction night
puisqu'il s'agit de 400 milliards
comme l'avait dit le président a sorti
de conférence de presse 400 milliards en
trois mois c'est une rapidité
extraordinaire je vous rappelle que
l'inflation réduction acte n'est pas
mise en œuvre pour le moment
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'était une pour ce plan
industriel toujours une simplification
drastique et nous avons avancé puisque
nous mettons des crédits d'impôts dans
le cadre d'être d'État ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire de la prévisibilité de la
visibilité et de la simplicité nous
avons également voté une loi qui permet
de simplifier les procédures
d'autorisation d'implantation de site
industriels et je dis bien simplifier je
ne dis pas réduire parce qu'en fait ce
que nous faisons c'est qu'au lieu de
faire en séquence les différents
processus les uns après les autres nous
les faisons en parallèle ça ira donc
beaucoup plus vite l'exemple que l'on
donne c'est celui des projets du piaques
où on pouvait mettre deux trois ou
quatre ans avant d'avoir obtenu une
autorisation et qui se feront maintenant
en moins de 6 mois
la troisième pointe de ce plan
industriel c'est d'être stratégique donc
on ne disperse pas les deniers on ne
disperse pas les efforts on les
concentre et on les concentre dans les
technologies de pointe numérique c'est
le TIPS hack dont vous m'avez parlé par
exemple ces batteries c'est tout ce qui
va servir à la fois à la transition
numérique à la transition écologique et
je crois que nous en France nous portons
aussi la santé qui également stratégique
donc un plan industriel financier
de simplification drastiques et
stratégique pour une économie européenne
très forte le deuxième point c'est bien
évidemment le marché intérieur et ce
marché intérieur nous voulons le
protéger nous voulons la réciprocité et
nous voulons être offensif quand nous
avons des intérêts à déployer nos forces
alors le protéger ce sont les
instruments notamment développés pendant
la présidence française de l'Union
européenne en tissuventions antidoping
anti-achat de nos entreprises par des
entreprises étrangères qui sont trop qui
sont subventionnés par leur état
la réciprocité c'est de dire que nous ne
laisserons pas une entreprise d'un pays
qui n'ouvre pas son marché public
candidaté à des marchés publics chez
nous c'est terminé
et la réciprocité il se retrouve
également dans les accords commerciaux
j'y reviendrai et ensuite offensif nous
allons parler des sanctions jamais dans
l'histoire de l'Union européenne on
avait mis en place autant de tension
aussi rapidement
offensif c'est également dire nous si
vous voulez rentrer sur notre territoire
vous allez devoir
souscrire à nos règles sociales nos
règles environnementales nos règles en
matière de standard par exemple
phytosanitaire et du coup les
entreprises évidemment étrangères elles
vont pas faire trois lignes de
production
elles vont faire une ligne de production
et donc comme ça nos standards vont se
déployer vous avez mentionné monsieur le
sélecteur gatelin le l'accord
d'investissement caille l'Union comme la
France est très claire on ne ré-ouvrira
pas il n'y aura pas de signature tant
que les sanctions sur les parlementaires
européens ne seront pas levés c'est
bloqué c'est bloqué et tous les pays
sont une énigme sur le sujet
donc le volet industriel protection du
marché intérieur
réciprocité et extension des accords je
crois qu'il faut qu'on se met tous dans
la tête nous sommes 440 millions de
consommateurs avec un pouvoir d'achat de
25000 euros par tête c'est la plus
grande économie du monde et nous n'avons
pas à rougir de nos avancées
technologiques qui à la 5G dans le monde
l'Europe il n'y a pas de 5g aux
États-Unis
qui fait les puces assez les plus
avancées alors vous m'excuserez en
matière de lithographie c'est une
entreprise des Pays-Bas donc je crois
qu'il faut que nous arrêtions de nous
sous-estimer et que nous assumions
pleinement que nous sommes une économie
très forte avec des personnes très
éduquées et que nous allons avoir des
besoins encore plus de formation et de
talents oui c'est pour ça qu'il y a ce
plan talent dans l'année des compétences
qui vient de sortir et il faut que nous
assumions d'être une puissance
internationale qui peut jouer totalement
à part égale avec les États-Unis et la
Chine et qui peut vendre des produits
qui ne sont pas stratégiques à la Chine
qui peut discuter de climat avec la
Chine qui peut demander à la Chine de ne
pas soutenir la Russie dans la guerre
avec l'Ukraine et qui ne livrera pas de
technologie sensible à la Chine
j'espère vous avoir convaincu sur ce
sujet il me reste des accords
commerciaux je ne vous oublie pas les
accords commerciaux c'est pareil nous
sommes très clair trois critères ils
doivent respecter tous nos accords
écologiques que ce soit l'accord de
Paris que ce soit comme 28 que soit la
biodiversité que ce soit et
déforestation il n'y a pas d'accord
commercial qui est signé sans respecter
nos engagements écologiques et
environnementaux le deuxième critère
c'est un critère que ces accords doivent
être équilibrés en termes de concession
et ça a bien été le cas et d'ailleurs
pour les accords écologiques je vous
renvoie à l'accord avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande qui est l'exemple type
de ça et ce n'est pas une lubie de
français puisque la France avec les
Pays-Bas avait fait un premier non
papier pour expliquer comment mettre des
accords environnementaux dans des
accords commerciaux donc l'écologie
des des concessions mutuelles
équilibrées c'est la base et le
troisième point c'est bien évidemment
que ce soit stratégique pour nous c'est
le cas par exemple quand on parle du
Chili et à nouveau nous sont très
claires sur le sujet
quand il vous parlez de clause miroir
nous demandons des mesures miroir
c'est-à-dire transverses pour qu'on ait
pas à les négocier dans chaque accord
commercial mais qu'elle s'applique à
tout et ça j'ai été très clair avec avec
la commission quand je leur ai parlé des
échanges et des accords commerciaux et
ils sont tout à fait sur cette ligne
c'est aussi dans leur intérêt ça leur
évite d'avoir à négocier ça à chaque
fois et ensuite vous parlez de bail
européen acte nous parlons de made in
Europe made in Europe en barque tous les
pays de l'Union européenne pourquoi
parce que nous ne produisons pas tout et
ce que nous voulons en fait c'est que
nous produisions en Europe pour créer
des entreprises en Europe et des emplois
en Europe et nous le faisons en
respectant les règles contrairement à
certains autres étatières pourquoi parce
que l'ordre et les règles c'est ce qui
va nous permettre d'avancer nos amendes
qui soient juste et efficace et qui ne
deviennent pas le Far West et donc il
est important et c'est à quoi nous
travaillons avec le plan industriel
à favoriser l'implantation d'usine en
Europe qui vont créer des emplois en
Europe et que nous pourrons nous fournir
en européen je crois que j'ai fait le
tour ou peut-être il faut que j'ajoute
sur les ce qu'on appelle le critique
donc l'acte et sur les matières
premières critiques là aussi je crois
qu'on est très pragmatique l'objectif
c'est de assurer la provisionnement en
matière première dont nous avons besoin
pour la transition énergétique et pour
la transition numérique en stockant en
exploitant là où on peut le faire dans
des conditions écologiques qui sont
bonnes et en diversifiant nos sources
d'approvisionnement et nous sommes allés
avec le G7 nous Européens même ce qu'on
appelle le G7 plus plus parfois même de
plus expliquer en fait couvrent les pays
asiatiques qui sont affinitaires de
façon à être une force sur le marché
international des matières premières qui
peut peser face à d'autres grandes
régions et que notre approvisionnement
soit assuré à nouveau c'est la fin d'une
certaine naïveté et un grand pragmatisme
sur le sujet
sur vous m'avez parlé
de ce qui se passe contre la Hongrie
avec les LGBT nous travaillons à une
coordination franco-allemande c'est pour
ça que vous n'avez pas encore entendu
parler de la France mais nous sommes
parfaitement au courant et la deadline
et la date limite et bien sûr
aujourd'hui
sur l'uranium et les sanctions vous
savez que avec les 11 États membres que
la France a réuni en marge du Conseil
énergies informel du 28 février la
France travaille à proposer à ses
partenaires des approvisionnements
alternatifs à la Russie nous voulons
développer des solutions européennes
souveraines de combustibles à l'image de
ce qui est fait aux États-Unis la France
elle n'est pas dépendante de la Russie
pour le fonctionnement de son parc
électro-nucléaire en revanche nous avons
recours pour une part minoritaire de
notre approvisionnement à des services
d'enrichissement d'uranium naturel
en Russie donc ce que nous essayons de
faire c'est de permettre aux autres pays
de ne pas être dépendant de ça et bien
sûr quand on discute des sanctions sur
le nucléaire
sur je crois que j'ai fait
le tour à moins que quelqu'un l'a
répondu à toutes vos questions
vous avez raison que fontex peut-être
effectivement se démultiplier maintenant
que nous avons un nouveau directeur
général pour les contournements c'est
vraiment pour l'instant discuter avec
les pays où les entreprises font du
contournement ce qui est la première
chose après je crois qu'il y a eu
effectivement des bateaux qui ont été
parfois stoppés
merci beaucoup je vais maintenant passer
la parole à Didier Marie
merci Président
je partage madame
vos propos sur la force
de l'Union européenne
comparativement
au poids des États-Unis et de la Chine
la seule différence avec ces deux
superpuissances c'est qu'une union
européenne est composée de 27 pays avec
27 gouvernements et 27 intérêts
particuliers qui ont parfois tendance à
trouver
avant des difficultés à se mettre
d'accord et ça se traduit
malheureusement lors de chacun des
conseils européens que nous suivons et
dont nous discutons avec vous
à cet égard on a évoqué un certain
nombre de sujets
pour ce qui concerne l'Ukraine il était
prévu de mettre sur la table à un
onzième paquet de sanction ça a été
discuté mais repousser
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quels
ont été les éléments bloquants qui ont
fait que
Conseil n'a pas souhaité aller plus loin
pour le moment sur sur le sujet
sur le crâne toujours
nous sommes engagés à leur fournir tout
l'armement nécessaire pour
résister à l'offensive des Russes et à
préparer une éventuelle contre-offensive
la difficulté aujourd'hui c'est que nous
sommes dans l'incapacité de leur fournir
dans la durée les munitions dont ils ont
besoin le commissaire breton a fait une
tournée européenne pour
mesurer ce qu'il était envisageable de
faire pour améliorer la situation mais
manifestement tout ça prendra du temps
et donc nous sommes obligés d'acheter
aujourd'hui sur étagère
ce qui existe pour
accompagner
l'Ukraine et donc se pose à la fois la
question de nos capacités industrielles
militaires et
d'autre part notre capacité financière à
dégager les moyens nécessaires au
soutien à l'Ukraine
[Musique]
deuxième sujet le marché d'électricité
nous présenter des choses de façon
positive
or j'ai cru comprendre que
l'Allemagne est son gouvernement
s'opposer actuellement à la
reconnaissance nucléaire comme énergie
neutre et comme énergie stratégique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où nous
en sommes des négociations avec notre
partenaire sur ce sujet
d'autre part pour ce qui concerne la
réponse à l'IRA sujet que vous avez
largement évoqué et sur
l'engagement de 0 émission net
quatre points de vigilance sur laquelle
vous pouvez peut-être nous donner votre
appréciation le premier c'est comment on
finance tout cela il n'y a pas de
nouveau financement et ça renvoie à un
sujet qui va nous occuper dans les mois
qui viennent celui de la révision ami
parcours du cadre financier pluriannuel
la nécessité des ressources propres
sujets qui ne semble pas beaucoup avancé
dans l'état actuel
des choses deuxième sujet concernant
zéro émission net c'est les risques de
distorsion entre les pays qui auront les
capacités de financer par eux-mêmes
les investissements et ceux qui ne les
auront pas et donc il peut y avoir une
repas de vitesse qui s'installe et donc
qu'est-ce que la Commission qu'est-ce
que le Conseil prévoit pour éviter ce
risque distorsion
une troisième inquiétude sur l'absence
d'objectifs contraignant
sur
les objectifs à atteindre puis enfin
vous l'avez rapidement évoqué mais les
questions de simplification
administrative ne doivent pas
s'accompagner effectivement
effectivement de recul sur le respect
de nos normes notamment matières
environnementale enfin un dernier sujet
très rapidement on aurait beaucoup de
choses à évoquer
nous sommes
confrontés aux prémices d'une crise
financière
les faillites de banques aux États-Unis
ou en Suisse
nous alertes est-ce que le Conseil a
évoqué
la nécessité de l'achèvement du marché
de l'union du marché de capitaux et ce
que la question de l'Union bancaire a
été évoqué et là encore
j'en viens aux difficultés
de la relation entre la France et
l'Allemagne puisque les Allemands ont
manifesté une certaine frilosité à
l'égard du mécanisme de garantie des
dépôts est-ce que sur ce sujet les
choses avanc ent ou non je vous remercie
merci Didier Jean-Yves Leconte
si monsieur le Président merci Madame la
Ministre
d'abord sur sur les sanctions l'Union
européenne les décides mais la mise en
oeuvre elle de chaque de chaque État
même si en novembre une décision du
conseil à
un peu précisé les choses en matière de
d'infraction
de sur les notions de contournement
toutefois est-ce que vous considérez que
on peut en rester avec les principes que
nous avons aujourd'hui en matière de
surveillance du respect des sanctions
c'est-à-dire finalement une fois que les
décisions sont prises en confit ça aux
États membres ne faudrait-il pas
au mieux
affirmer le besoin d'un nofac Européen
ou au moins donner des nouvelles
compétences au parc européen sur ce
sujet pour en tout cas les pays qui font
partie de cette coopération renforcée si
on ne le fait pas maintenant je me
demande quand est-ce qu'on avancera sur
ce sujet on perçoit bien que
il y a une question majeure de
crédibilité de nos sanctions par rapport
aux sanctions américaines et la raison
pour laquelle il faut avancer sur ce
point deuxième
question
la question des céréales ukrainiennes
les
[Musique]
Ukrainiens ont trouvé avec les Européens
des voies différentes que les ports du
sud de l'Ukraine pour les évacuer et
pour pouvoir les mettre sur les marchés
mondiaux sauf que après compte tenu de
leurs qualités de leur prix il reste en
Europe
qu'est-ce qui va être fait pour
finalement
accompagner les Ukrainiens dans leurs
besoins de commercialiser à l'export
leur production et faire en sorte que ça
ne déstabilise pas nos propres marchés
autre question un peu dans la
foulée de Didier Marie sur les prémices
d'une crise financière on voit les taux
qui qui augmentent et qui peuvent
engendrer de nouveaux risques
donc c'est une première inquiétude et la
deuxième inquiétude c'est des taux qui
augmentent alors que nous avons besoin
d'investissement en matière de Green
Deal et aussi
en matière et ça a été évoqué toutes les
industries qui savent faire de la
mécanique et qui pourraient aller vers
des productions de munitions en
particulier et bien si elles n'ont pas
des taux intéressants pour investir le
font pas donc est-ce que vous considérez
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des taux qui
sont totalement décalés par rapport à
nos besoins
dernière question sur la question
migratoire j'avais évoqué lors du débat
préalable au Conseil européen à la
question de la Tunisie en fait on a
l'impression que l'Union européenne
était tamisée par rapport à ce qui se
passe dans ce pays
avec les risques que ça engendre et
qu'on voit aujourd'hui parce qu'avec ce
qui s'est passé en matière de de
propos du président vis-à-vis des
subsahariens ça engendrait des départs
rapides avec énormément de morts vers
vers l'Europe il y a la question du
respect de l'État droit dans ce pays
est-ce que on va avoir une réaction qui
sera encore plus mauvaise que celle
qu'on a eu en 2011 ou est-ce qu'on va
essayer pour une fois d'avoir vis-à-vis
d'un pays qui est vraiment en situation
très très compliquée et et qui est
majeur finalement pour pour assurer
la stabilité de l'Union européenne
est-ce qu'on va avoir une politique
vis-à-vis de la Tunisie et de ce qui s'y
passe aujourd'hui et sur les sur
migratoire
il me semble que depuis les propositions
du du Conseil européen sur le pacte
d'asile migration nous avons quand même
deux éléments majeurs nouveaux le
premier c'est notre ce que nous avons
vécu avec les réfugiés temporaires
c'est-à-dire finalement sans Dublin et
avec le droit au travail d'une part et
deuxièmement une situation du marché du
travail en Europe qui est différente et
qui mériterait que le Conseil demande à
la Commission de revoir son ses
propositions initiales à l'aune
finalement de l'expérience ukrainienne
et de l'évolution du marché du travail
est-ce que sur ces points nous pourrions
avancer merci beaucoup
Gisèle Jordan
madame la ministre donc d'abord merci
pour la clarté donc de votre exposé et
des réponses que vous avez apportées nos
collègues jusque là moi je souhaiterais
revenir sur donc
les l'articulation en trois points que
vous avez donc évoqué en ce qui concerne
la Moldavie
alors et notamment par rapport au
contrat d'association et à la
problématique du Partenariat oriental
bon il se trouve que compte tenu de la
situation de guerre déclenchée donc en
nucléaire et des répercussions directes
qu'il y a eu sur la Moldavie il y a il y
a eu une souplesse de l'Union européenne
pour pouvoir adapter donc ces réponses
par rapport à la Moldavie notamment tous
ceux qui concernait les marchés les
sports et notamment tout ce qui était
lié donc à des facilités donc
commerciale donc on a su donc s'ajuster
alors moi la question que je souhaite
évoquer avec vous et que j'avais évoqué
d'ailleurs lors d'un Conseil européen
aux intervenais c'est que à la comment
va s'articuler et je souhaiterais que
s'articule plus exactement les acquis de
la politique de partenariats oriental
avec la corde association qui rentre en
vigueur comme vous vous avez en 2016
mais qui prévoyait énormément donc de de
contre de contraintes et d'axes que ce
soit sur l'axe de de
l'évolution
démocratique des droits de la justice au
sein même donc de la Moldavie de lutte
contre la corruption il n'y avait pas
que les accords commerciaux c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus large que
nous avions d'ailleurs donc évalué et
pour lesquels nous avons des instruments
il y avait des instruments donc au
niveau
parlementaire donc en Ukraine il y avait
un conseil de surveillance pour
l'évolution dont de cet accord
commercial et ce me semble à l'annonce
de du processus d'entrée d'un lieu et de
basculement vers le processus
d'élargissement il ne faudrait pas à mon
sens que tous les efforts fait par la
Moldavie et par l'Ukraine mais là moi je
suis monsieur la Moldavie puisque donc
c'est ce que vous aviez évoqué tout à
l'heure j'aimerais donc savoir si dans
la réactivité au niveau européen il y a
donc d'abord une
convergence entre les bureaux qui
s'occupent tant du sujet de
l'élargissement que du sujet donc du
Partenariat oriental sachant qu'au
niveau du soutien financier le
Partenariat oriental donc par rapport
donc à cette situation
dramatique anukraine donc et en Moldavie
par par répercussion s'est adapté et que
nous apportons le soutien financier donc
vous disiez tout à l'heure que vous
aviez besoin justement qu'on aide
en soutenant donc ces démarches mais je
souhaiterais que ce soit vraiment que
les deux dispositifs soient mises en
synergie parce que j'ai l'impression que
pour l'instant on est dans deux process
un peu étanche voilà
merci
le Président je vous remercie je vous
remercie de vos questions alors je vais
peut-être les prendre un tout petit peu
plus dans l'ordre que tout à l'heure car
elles sont moins convergentes
c'est vrai nous sommes 27 pays et nous
avons des différences mais quand vous
discutez avec les non européens ce qui
les frappe eux c'est que nous sommes 27
pays qui faisons bloc bloc sur la
réglementation des données rgpd qu'ils
ont bien fini par ils ont bien dû devoir
s'adapter bloc sur le climat nous nous
avons des frottements mais eux ce qu'ils
voient c'est qu'il y a une taxe carbone
aux frontières une stratégie très claire
à le dirigeon 2050 blog sur les
véhicules électriques puisque finalement
c'est bien resté que c'est la fin des
véhicules thermiques en 2035 donc pour
pour l'extérieur nous sommes un bloc
maintenant c'est sûr nous devons
négocier et nous et nous avons à chaque
fois à travailler discuter parce que
nous avons quand même des cultures et
des histoires qui sont et des
spécificités industrielles et
économiques et un peu différentes
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
le onzième paquet qui est effectivement
et je crois que c'était votre question
également
monsieur sénateur Lecomte nous
travaillons sur ce onzième paquet avec
dans l'esprit de s'attacher au
contournement des sanctions par tous les
moyens donc je pourrais revenir vous
voir si vous le souhaitez quand nous
aurons quand ce sera finalisé je pense
que ce sera intéressant mais c'est
vraiment aujourd'hui ce qui occupe une
bonne partie des travaux des travaux
pardon et des réflexions sur le sujet
sur
les munitions parfaitement je crois que
c'est en fait ce que c'est agression de
la Russie envers l'Ukraine a mis en
évidence c'est que nous n'avions pas de
capacité de défense qui était
nous avons les capacités de défense de
pays qui ont vécu avec les dividendes de
la paix la fin des années 90 et la chute
du mur et la prospérité nous allions
tous vivre dans des démocraties je crois
que nous sommes en train d'inverser très
très rapidement quand même et c'est
aussi en moins d'un an qu'il a été
décidé de mettre en place à la fois
l'Europe de la défense et vous savez
comme moi que c'était impensable jusqu'à
cette guerre et là nous avons la
boussole stratégique nous avons des
travaux sur des troupes et des
militaires conjoints nous d'ailleurs il
y a des missions conjointes comme vous
savez dans beaucoup de pays de l'Union
européenne et aussi en dehors de l'Union
Européenne nous avons les fonds
d'investissement qui ont été portés par
le commissaire breton et nous avons
cette volonté d'accroître très très vite
la capacité de production industrielle
et je crois que dans la réponse à
l'Ukraine ce que nous faisons c'est
d'être très pragmatique de leur fournir
ce dont ils ont besoin au moment où les
en ont besoin sans nous à moindre rire
nos capacités de défense et avec les
munitions et les missiles c'est ce qu'on
on leur fournisse qui existe et c'est
remboursé par l'Union européenne pour
les pays qui se défont de leur munition
et de leur missile nous investissons
nous avons mis en commun un milliard
pour des achats conjoints et nous avons
tous décidé d'accélérer la production de
munitions et de missiles alors c'est
vrai il va y avoir une question de
financement mais il y a aussi une
question de changement de logique
industriel ou on était plus dans cette
idée de répondre à la demande alors que
maintenant nous allons fournir pour
qu'il y ait sur étagère pour reprendre
votre expression ce qui est ce dont les
Ukrainiens auront besoin et puis que
nous nous soyons assurés d'avoir
effectivement tout ce que nous avons
besoin en même temps donc ça va prendre
c'est forcément ça ne change pas du jour
au lendemain il y a quelque chose et ça
s'applique à la fois à la défense ça
s'applique à la fois
au plan industriel et à la transition
énergétique je le rappelle jamais nous
n'avons eu de taux de chômage aussi bas
donc pour faire des projets
d'investissement il faut bien évidemment
de la planification mais il faut aussi
des personnes et je crois et c'était un
peu le sens de votre question sur la
migration que oui nous avons à nous
poser la question du de l'emploi qui
existe et de comment augmenter
nos notre
force nos ressources humaines alors je
crois qu'il y a
de nous pouvons faire beaucoup mieux sur
l'emploi des jeunes et sur l'emploi des
seniors et évidemment le gouvernement
s'y attache il y a des propositions à ce
sens et nous devons aussi nous poser la
question et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui
avait été fait pour le sujet du
nucléaire cet hiver d'avoir du personnel
qualifié qui viennent d'autres pays que
la France pour nous aider à accélérer
sur ces sur ces industries qui sont
stratégiques et qui vont nous permettre
de faire la transition énergétique
sur la réforme du marché de
l'électricité et l'Allemagne je vais pas
nier les différences et d'ailleurs vous
les voyez tous les jours dans les
journaux donc j'aurais beaucoup de mal à
faire ça c'est vrai nous n'avons pas du
tout le même énergie mix
nous partons avec une énergie qui est
largement des carbonée mais nous n'avons
pas le même énergie mix mais nous avons
les mêmes objectifs de décarbonation et
c'est cela que nous mettons sur la table
toujours dans le dialogue avec
l'Allemagne le meilleur moyen d'arriver
à nos objectifs de décarbonation c'est
que chacun part des forces propres qu'il
a en matière de bouquet énergétique et
nous nous devons et en espagnol une
haché s'y attache absolument consolidé
notre outil nucléaire et accélérer là
dessus
nous allons y arriver
sur la question des financements
effectivement
la Commission est en train d'estimer
s'il y a besoin de financement
supplémentaire je vais dire deux choses
à ce sujet puisque vous m'avez aussi
parlé de fragmentation en Europe le
l'accord qui a été fait quand on a parlé
d'une aide zéro industriac et de réponse
à lire c'est que dans les financements
les pays qui peuvent le faire
on assoupli les règles d'être d'État
mais dans un cadre commun et on permet
les crédits d'impôts pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas faire ça en revanche
l'accord qui a été trouvé c'est de leur
dire vous pouvez utiliser les fonds du
plan de relance irrésilien sans donc ce
qui viennent de l'emprunt commun et vous
pouvez utiliser les fonds de coefficient
pour la réponse à l'irra ce qui permet
effectivement de maintenir des
conditions qui soient équitables pour
tout le monde et je ne vous apprends
rien si je vous dis que de l'extrémité
ouest de l'Europe à l'extrémité Est
du sud au nord beaucoup de pays
effectivement en partie aussi à cause de
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre ont eu du
mal à mettre en place les plans
d'investissement qu'ils avaient discuté
dans le cadre du plan de relance et de
résilience et donc ces délais cette
réorientation de fonds
européenne a été flexible et pragmatique
mais on va on va en revenir au goulet
d'étranglement et que sont les
ressources humaines sur le territoire de
l'Union européenne
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr que ce soit
indifférent franco-allemand sur ce sujet
je pense qu'il y a des différences qui
sont plus par morcelés ou en tous les
cas entre pays européens
vous avez en a parlé d'Europe de la
défense pendant des décennies et on a
fini par la faire à cette union de
marché de capitaux c'est union bancaire
avec des taux d'intérêt qui monte on va
arriver à la faire parce que c'est
urgent c'est ce que vous disiez avec des
taux qui montent quand on a besoin
d'investissement il faut qu'on fluidifie
le passage de l'épargne dans de
en fait des empreintes d'État vers des
activités plus productrices et pour ça
il faut absolument qu'on accélère donc
je vois d'ailleurs
madame Lagarde tout à l'heure il nous
allons en discuter
sur
les céréales
ukrainiennes
on a évidemment aidé d'abord avec les
corridors comme vous savez à les faire
sortir ces céréales des territoires
parce qu'elles étaient bloquées et
qu'elle puisse atteindre les pays
d'Afrique et du Moyen-Orient nous avons
aussi
un système qui est mise en place que
nous avons libéralisation d'arriver on a
supprimé tarifs pour ces céréales de
façon à ce que d'autres pays puissent y
accéder il y a un paquet de soutiens
financiers pour les agriculteurs des
pays voisins de l'Ukraine et puis on
aide aussi les pays de l'autre côté de
la Méditerranée à acheter ces céréales
quand les prix sont trop élevés et au
début effectivement on a vu une envolée
des prix en partie avec des craintes sur
la capacité d'offres en partie peut-être
de la spéculation voilà et nous allons
continuer en fait de nous assurer qu'il
y ait pas de gras de douane sur toutes
ces sur toutes ces céréales et qu'elle
puisse arriver aux personnes qui en ont
le plus besoin
c'est sûr est-ce que oui
madame la sénatrice Jourda je crois que
je vous dois quelque chose sur la
Moldavie absolument
il y a
vous avez raison de souligner que l'on
doit toujours s'attacher à mettre en
cohérence les différents processus qui
existaient et qui
sont et qui sont je l'espère convergent
mais en faisant tous les cas c'est
quelque chose qu'on a rappelé à la fois
au conseil je vais juste voir à côté
d'une petite histoire donc je suis allée
avec les ministres de l'Europe femme en
Moldavie pour la journée de la femme
rencontrer la présidence les ministres
etc ce point a été effectivement
souligné et nous l'avons rapporté à la
Commission européenne en revenant donc
c'est quelque chose sur lesquels on va
vraiment s'attacher et notamment les
progrès qui sont effectués dans les
différents domaines la Moldavie a
vraiment besoin d'aide technique sur
tous ses acquis et sur l'état de droit à
la présidente et absolument
remarquable puisque comme vous savez
elle réforme la justice
un coup élevé
je sais qu'il y a une délégation du
Sénat qui va aller en Moldavie et si
vous vous souhaitez qu'on en parle avant
je serai très heureuse de vous de vous
voir ou d'en parler au téléphone
vous avez répondu
clairement me semble-t-il à toutes les
interpellations et les interrogations
qui vous ont été transmises
c'est vrai que
à vos entendre quand même c'est vrai que
tout va très bien je suis pas très sûr
quand même que qu'on en soit là c'est
pas une critique c'est un constat c'est
pas c'est normal vous êtes là aussi pour
nous nous faire la relation d'abord du
conseil et de ce que vous en avez
ressenti
très clairement
nous nous souhaitons que la vous l'avez
bien compris quel que soit nos
sensibilités que la France soit plus
encore plus présente ça ne ces conseils
l'Europe on la connaît bien vous l'avez
dit c'est 27 États donc c'est vaste
y compris en matière de choix en matière
culturelle vous avez dit l'Europe est un
bloc si on va voir Victor urban demain
je suis pas sûr qu'ils vous disent que
on est vraiment un bloc enfin voilà je
veux dire faut pas non plus
cela étant on a besoin de solidarité
européenne dans ces sites dans cette
situation qu'on connaît c'est vrai et a
priori c'est ce que vous me disiez tout
de suite le Conseil va dans ce sens là
et donc c'est ce que évidemment nous ici
au Sénat nous souhaitons et nous
essayons de contribuer autant que faire
ce peu à tout cela de plus en plus
en tous les cas merci de toutes ces
explications de toutes ces réponses et
je crois que tous les collègues étaient
satisfaits
voilà j'ai une petite communication à
vous faire les collègues je raccompagne
madame la ministre j'ai une petite
restait deux minutes s'il vous plaît